well i think the way that we avoid this
third nation
uh wide lockdown is by observing the
tiered approach
we've got for as long as is necessary
and you know we judge that we do need to
maintain that
for now those measures do expire at the
end of february parliament will have a
role to review what should happen at
that point
but if we can get a rapid deployment of
the vaccine during the
first quarter of next year and then the
spring arrives
and spring and summer weather is far
less conducive to the virus than the
depths
of winter can be i think those factors
coming together means that we can see a
way out of this
during the course of early next summer
how concerned are you about a lockdown
in january though that's what the
scientists are predicting
well i think it's too early to say if we
if we stay
in how effective they are though can't
we because you know we're out of this
one tomorrow and
quite a lot of the cases have been
halved in the high-risk areas
so it's a very quick effective way of of
getting the virus back under control
it is and you know what we know is that
the tier 1 approach
doesn't generally keep the r value below
one so it's something you can only
really
continence where you have a very low
prevalence rate but the the tier three
obviously
has got quite a lot of similarities to
the full lockdown anyway we're doing
that we're maintaining that in the
areas of highest prevalence you know and
tier two
uh does actually uh have you know a much
more effective impact
than the the tier one measure so
provided we maintain
the tiered approach for as long as
necessary i don't think it will be
necessary to go back into another full
lockdown but you can't rule it out at
this stage you can't rule anything out
because this is a rapidly developing
situation
the government has to respond to the
epidemiological evidence that it will
have at a given time
uh it's always difficult to predict
exactly what will happen
but we judge at the moment that if we uh
stick to the course with these
tiered approaches at this stage then
that might get us through the winter